getting crank called on one hour's sleep
at three four five in the morning that
exposes who you actually are and you're
calling your house and you're telling
sweet stand how many drift your phone
yes I need to speak to guests his name
is Gary vaynerchuk and I can spell that
for you it's v-a-y-n-e-r-c-h-u-k
a first name is Gary
yes please
thank you
yes is this Gary this is Gary Gary hello
my name is Tom crush and you're
destroying my life I'm sorry
everyone keeps telling me to crush
things some man actually physically
crushed me
what should I do
you should tell them to crush off what
is crush it and why does everyone want
to do it to me I'm not sure
what I thought so too it's almost like a
superhero I agree all right all right
bro thank you for your help Gary no
problem my friend bye-bye